[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
biggest shocks that have been seen in
the movie screens let's get to the top
10 Countdown at number 10 we have Bruce
Bruce the Shar is the antagonist in
Steven Spielberg's 1975 Thriller film
called Jaws Bruce is a great white shock
who terrorizes Amity Island a fictional
Coastal town by attacking and murdering
everyone who Ventures into the ocean it
was a great white Shar also known as a
white pointer or a white death known for
its large size aggressiveness and
powerful jaws which are filled with rows
of Razor Shar teeth in the movie Bruce's
size is not explicitly stated but he is
portrayed as being exceptionally large
and formidable and later it was
confirmed that he was around 7.62 M or
25 ft long number nine the giant Mao
from the 1999 movie called Deep Blue Sea
the giant Maco is a genetically
engineered creature a Shar created by
scientists as a part of an experiment to
find a cure for Alzheimer's disease the
Shar was designed to have a larger brain
in the hope of studying its brain would
provide insights into the disease in the
movie The Shar is portrayed as being
exceptionally large and Powerful highly
intelligent as well and aggressive able
to outsmart and outmaneuver the
characters the human characters the
giant ma was stated to be 8 m of 20 6 ft
long number eight Shocktopus Shocktopus
is a fictional genetically engineered
creature created by a private research
company known as Blue Water it was
designed as an experimental super weapon
for the US Navy using the DNA of an
octopus and a shock however it goes on a
rampage after its electrical impulse
colar is destroyed during testing and it
escapes to Mexico where it continues to
kill people the creature appears in two
other films including shakers versus
Terracuda and shus versus whale wolf
where it battles other hybrid creatures
and it is around 9 M or 30 ft in all
movies number seven the giant great
white Shar seen in the 1981 Italian
horror film directed by Enzo G
castellari kind of like an Italian
version of Jaws the story goes as
follows a young man gets killed wind
surfing at Port Harbor by a massive
great white shark the mayor dismisses
the threat believing that it may
jeopardize his candidature for election
shock Nets are then built around or
thrown around but the shock evades them
and breaches them an attack wi surface
all the time and so The Story Goes On
Till the Shar is killed this shock was
35 ft in length or more than 11 M SC
number five the black demon this Shar
will be seen in a few days time in April
this year
2023 according to the stories from
fishermen all around Baja California the
black demon is a massive black shot
species that haunts the waters in and
around the Feld seas in many moments
from the trailer we witness a giant
shark the size of Megalodon perhaps 60
ft or more around 18 M on a vengeful
mission to finish off humans stuck on an
oil rig as soon as they fall into the
water this black demon more resembles a
great white shark than a Megalodon even
though its size is three four times
bigger than a great white shark number
four the mega shark seen in the Mega
Shark versus Giant octop movie which is
a 2009 American British monster disaster
film an oceanographer named Emma mcneel
is studying whale migration patterns in
an experimental submarine in Alaska then
a military helicopter drops Sona
transmitters into the water causing a PT
of whales to go berserk and crash into a
glacier the crash then throws down two
prehistoric creatures a giant shark and
a giant octopus which fight for
dominance the Shar there was thought to
be a Megalodon specimen that is over 70
ft or 21 M long number three the second
Megalodon this is the second Megalodon
from the same movie The me it was seen
consuming the first one that was caught
the second specimen was a female and it
terrorized the Seas for quite some time
until the protagonist Taylor wounds the
Beast with his damage underwater
submersible and then stabs her in the
eye spilling its blood and attracting a
swarm of sharks that Devour the dying
Meg this Megalodon was twice the size of
the first one at an estimated length of
80 to 90 ft or 24 to 27 M it also gave
birth to a live young Megalodon in the
end before it was stor to shreds and
this young me will be the star in the
second movie The Me 2 the
trench number two the Jaguar Shar this
shock is a fictional monster species of
shock in the 2004 movie called The Life
Aquatic with Steve zizu the shock is the
main subject of the movie as it is the
creature that zizu a renowned
oceanographer want wants to capture and
kill in order to avenge the death of his
friend and crewmate called estaban who
was killed by the shark the Jaguar shark
is described as a mythical creature that
is rarely seen by humans it is said to
be a large white shark with Jaguar likee
spots on its skin it is 30 m or 100 ft
long and the Jaguar Shar in the end was
a symbol of the beauty and mystery of
the ocean and number one Pinocchio's
shock in every pinio movie Will except
for the one in Shrek the puppet always
finds his way into danger and the end of
the movie he would be swallowed with his
father GTO by a giant sea creature in
the 2002 remake the sea monster was a
gigantic Shar of Titanic proportions
easily over 30 m or 100 ft in length it
was so huge that inside its belly
Pinocchio and gapo were able to move
around with ease and had enough time to
plot and Escape its design was similar
to a great white shock but of course it
was way way bigger so those are the top
10 biggest movie sharks I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam